le deuxième sujet et qui est directement
lié au débat que nous avons eu tout à
l'heure sur la possibilité d'implanter
des réacteurs nucléaires notamment de
petites tailles en dehors des sites
nucléaires existants c'est la question
de la sécurité
différence entre sûreté nucléaire c'est
ce que ce dont s'occupe la SN en matière
de risque accidentel et la sécurité
nucléaire qui est la lutte contre les
actes de malveillance y compris les
attaques les attaques criminelles les
attaques attentats le risque de
cybersécurité là on est devant un sujet
qui bien évidemment est plus complexe
pour un petit réacteur qui serait
implanté dans une zone industrielle
voire à proximité d'une agglomération
qu'un réacteur qui sera implanté sur un
gros site nucléaire qui est déjà
sécurisé avec avec beaucoup de moyens y
compris des moyens d'intervention qui
permettent d'attendre l'arrivée des
forces de l'ordre lorsqu'il y a eu une
intrusion criminelle sur le site donc ce
sont des sujets qui sont imposés qu'ils
doivent être portés par les exp des
futurs SMR donc je dis attention
c'est un sujet qu'il ne faut pas perdre
de vue parce que autant il est tout à
fait tout à fait justifié de
s'interroger sur le développement des
usages de ces petits réacteurs pour
pouvoir faire de la chaleur de
l'hydrogène pour pouvoir
accompagner la décarbonation de
l'industrie et donc implanter ces
réacteurs ailleurs que dans des gros
sites nucléaires avec des usages
immédiats locaux sans transport mais
attention la sécurité peut devenir un
sujet plus lourd à traiter que celui de
la sûreté donc il faut vraiment intégrer
les deux composantes dès les débuts avec
la recherche de sécurité passive de la
même manière qui a surté passive dont je
parlais tout à l'heure